the holiday season isn't complete
without holiday music and here to get us
in the festive mood is singer-songwriter
chadwig Johnson I always love to see you
chadway thank you so much for being here
thank you Jillian so congratulations you
two holiday music is my favorite kind of
music but how fun is it to put out this
single tell us a little bit about it you
know it's super fun you know the
holidays are so nostalgic and I think we
all have memories from our childhood and
whatnot so it's really a special time of
year for all of us and no way to
highlight that but through music so yeah
my new Christmas single is called it's
almost Christmas and we did some of that
we did some throwing back to some of
those nostalgic things like mistletoe or
Saint Nick but then we really tried to
highlight the importance of who you're
spending the the holidays with and and
how important it is to be with people
you love that's what makes it truly
special no that is really special and as
you get older I think you start to
realize that more and more but you also
start to miss those moments of your
childhood so I think that's really fun
to kind of incorporate all of that into
a song and you're doing something
special to kick it off tell us about
your performance at the Italian American
Girl yeah well you know I'm gonna head
over to LA and I'm gonna do the the 29th
there at Feinstein's and kick off the
whole uh Holiday Tour there and then I'm
going to be back in Vegas on December
1st to the Italian American Club which
is a very special place for me you know
that showroom is one of the first places
that I ever did a big show in Vegas so
it seemed like the perfect place to come
back for a nostalgic show so I'm really
excited well I'm excited you're doing it
there and I just have to say I met you
years ago and it was actually at the
Italian American Club you were singing
on stage I came up to you after and I
said I I gotta tell everyone about you I
have to just meet you and we've been
friends ever since so it's really
special for not only you but for all of
your fans and the people that continue
to support you so how does it feel to
have people come out there singing your
songs and also getting to hear your new
songs yeah you know that's what music is
all about and it's been a journey
especially when we talk about the
Italian American Club you know that's
why I named the show celebrate me home
because it is like going home every time
I play there and I haven't played there
in a long time but it's fun to to take
um you know people on a journey all
these years and introduce new music and
especially original music is so
important to me and so and the Las Vegas
Community is just incredible at
supporting artists and entertainers so
I'm really excited about it well we're
excited for you and if I'm I'm driving
to my car I'm going to do some holiday
shopping I want to listen to your song
where can I find it well like I said
it's called it's almost Christmas and it
is everywhere you stream your music
Spotify Apple music Amazon it actually
goes on pre-order today and it will
release on the 29th is when you'll
actually get it yeah amazing well I'm
glad you're here today we're kicking it
off and if people want to come see your
show at the Italian American Club tell
them again when it is and how they can
get tickets yep that's December 1st at
the Italian American Club showroom and
their website is IAC vegas.com or you
can get them on my website as well
chadwickjohnson.com ugh I love it have a
congratulations all the information on
your screen if you want to come hear the
show I can't wait to hear the single
thanks for being here